Hello doctor, if not, can you
tell us about the doses that
people have received and about how they
are asking for the goal is to ask for more
vaccines
for nothing?
1 We were saying that
around 60 thousand doses of
coronavirus vaccine here in clark county
these vaccines have been administered not
only by health district personnel
but also
by other organizations participating
in this campaign such as the county
the cities of people are and not las vegas
as well as the university  the
university of nevada or in the ub and the
universities of everything informal
and also the hospitals and other
medical providers here the
community has been an effort of a large number
of people not only of
health destination and so far we have been able to
vaccinate  make another 60 thousand people,
right now in the
health district has an approximate number of
25,000 doses of vaccine  The available ones that
we hope will be administered in
the course of the next few days while
waiting for the next shipment of vaccines
from the federal government that should arrive
next week in order to continue this
campaign,
we also wanted to say that he is the
vaccination center that we have open
in the center  de assmann that has been
operating for several days
will not be open it has to handle itself
from Friday to Sunday
because it is now in a transition with
the electronic appointment system of
this site and therefore it will not be
available during these three days
weekend and next week they will
begin to offer their
services again.
We also want to emphasize that we are in the
midst of this epidemic, unfortunately
our community has suffered from
the pandemic, we here in Clark County
have already had more than 200,000
people diagnosed by the
coronavirus which represents a
tremendous challenge for him
social and economic life  In this
community,
we have also lost almost three thousand
lives because of him and his friends, which
affects many families in this
community, both those who lost
their loved ones and close ones, as well as
others who have lost friends and
co-workers, and it is something that
has  a negative impact on our
daily life and therefore we want the
community to
be given the opportunity to be vaccinated the
number of vaccines available right
now is still not at a
sufficient level to meet the
needs of everyone in the community
but we know that the number of  The number of vaccines
that we receive in the coming weeks will
and will be increasing and therefore
the opportunities that
we will all attend to be vaccinated will be greater and
what we do ask that once
that opportunity arrives please take
that  opportunity to go because this
is how you protect yourself and you are also
protecting your loved ones and
everyone in this community because it
is  The possibility of
the virus continuing to be transmitted in the
county is decreasing. This is very important for everyone
in Nexo Fernando
Dr.
Well, look, you'll see in relation to what
the commissioner Patrick has commented before,
and well, we're going to
ask you questions, but we don't want how  She was
saying about the feeling that
the vaccination system is being a disaster
so that people are then minimal and
don't go, we don't have the intention,
but we do want to know more or
less how the vaccination system is going,
then I  I want to
ask you how many vaccinations
last week you said you expected to
vaccinate between 40,000
and 45,000 people a week in southern Nevada this
was the first one
and how many have been vaccinated what problems
have there been and how do you think they will be
solved and  how do you think
the vaccination system will be working in the
coming weeks thanks to fernando
bueno our
goal of reaching forty  and
so many wet of marginalized people
is something that we
hope to achieve and next week
this week to
vaccinate more than 25 thousand people
in our estimate that would be
enough to
practically finish the vaccines
that we have right now in the
storage in the health district
and from there if we receive
enough vaccines through the state,
when will it be then to vaccinate at least 45 46
thousand people weekly
and according to what the commission now sees
previously as information and
requests that we have made to the
federal government  If it is and another, they are met with a
new administration that has
very ambitious plans
and to expand vaccination, well,
we could reach even higher figures
with the direct assistance of the federal government
here in Clark County, helping
us with more vaccines and with and with also
resources so that we can open a greater
number of mass vaccination centers
'n  Ours and that answers your question yes
yes yes it answers the question then
in view of the fact that yes we are going to be able
to quickly achieve the goal of
vaccinating as many people right the week that
40 45,000 well that means almost 200 thousand
a month not
a number  big we are going to see that we are going to
advance in phases, right in phases of
priority and age that the people who
are attentive can not
see us on our television channel
as what do they have to do
the message I think the  Last week
to register where we
would be notified when our turn will be.
I don't know if you can tell us a little about
it.
Well, ours our website
has a what is it called?
A line is a scope for
people to sign up to receive  receive
your vaccine
and also
that same page people can
reach other sites where there is also
information about the
evacuation campaign on such sites as for
example the site that is called  ama in a
high one that offers very good information
and also offers how to access
vaccination sites or other resources
provided by the state and also from
our web pages you can also access
the site of
the state health department page where
there are also  additional resources but in
general most of the
information and resources that people
need and clark county can
enjoy on our website
and